comment protéger une espèce quand il ne
reste presque plus de territoire ou
d'habitat pour assurer sa survie
et que faire quand cette espèce est un
reptile qui suscite la peur chez bien
des gens voilà justement le défi
contente de relever dans le sud de
l'ontario
[Musique]
nous sommes dans la réserve provincial
de la prairie ojibway près de windsor en
ontario
jonathan choquette est en mission ici
pour trouver une espèce unique
le serpent masaga on marche à travers
les auteurs on cherche pour vraiment des
sites de gestation fait que ça en fait
c'est des sites où l'herbe est plus bas
que les alentours puis ou ce qu'on
trouve aussi des tas de branches
au fait ça pour vraiment déterminer si
encore des serpents ici l'équipe
ratissent le terrain chaque semaine de
l'été mais jusqu'à présent aucune trace
de serpents
[Musique]
on est en train de vraiment observer le
déclin des populations
lorsque moi j'ai commencé le travail est
ici environ l'année 2013 il y avait
environ 12 serpent masse aux gars de
restant ici puis depuis l'année passée
on a trouvé seulement un serpent cette
année maintenant on n'a rien trouvé
le serpent masaga fait pourtant partie
du paysage de l'ontario depuis des
milliers d'années
c'est le seul serpents venimeux de la
province ce sont de petits serpents à
sonnette
ce ne sont pas comme les gros crotales
du texas ils sont relativement petit
on trouve en ontario deux populations de
serpents en masse à saugues à une
population vit autour de la baie
georgienne entre la péninsule de brousse
jusqu'au sud de sudbury
cette population est considérée à risque
mais elle est stable
leur population est en danger des gens
là dessus parce qu'ils en ont peur voilà
le principal problème à ça s'ajoute le
développement de la villégiature et des
routes qui entravent la connexion entre
les populations
on sait que ça nuit au serpent massada
l'autre population vit au sud des grands
lacs
côté américain comme canadien mais en
ontario cette population est très mal en
point ont trouvé des groupes le long du
lac erié tous liés les uns aux autres et
avec l'urbanisation et le développement
massif de l'agriculture l'habitat du
serpent a été cédée en nombreuses
petites poches avec le temps tout a
disparu
aujourd'hui dans le sud de l'ontario il
ne reste que deux endroits où l'on peut
voir se sert pas d'abord dans la prairie
aux hiboux et près de windsor
mais comme on l'a dit cette population
est sur le point de disparaître et
l'autre endroit c'est dans la tourbière
winfried près de niagara
ici la population se porte un peu mieux
grâce à tout un travail de préservation
nous sommes en juillet une équipe
parcourt le terrain en quête de serpents
on cherche des femelles en gestation
alors on arpente tout le secteur chaque
fois qu'on trouve un endroit où il y un
peu de lumière qui filtre entre les
feuilles c'est là que se tiennent les
massages yoga
après quelques heures de marche un
massage yoga au beau milieu d'un sentier
nous récoltons des données
démographiques
nous notons leur poids nous prenons des
photos pour bien voir les marques sur
leur dos car c'est comme ça qu'on les
différencie ces tâches sont un peu comme
nous empreintes digitales nous pouvons
ainsi savoir s'il s'agit d'un nouveau
serpent ou d'un individu déjà identifié
celui là une longue queue donc on croit
que c'est mal
on va l'emmener au laboratoire pour
vérifier après analyse c'est bel et bien
un mal le lendemain il est relâché
on cherche précisément des femelles en
gestation car elles sont à la base d'un
projet de rétablissement de population
on attrape les femelles déjà en
gestation et on les amène au laboratoire
on leur fournit de la nourriture de
l'eau fraîche et un environnement
sécuritaire pour qu'elle puisse mettre
bas à l'abri des prédateurs à niague y
mène depuis des années
les travaux pour tenter de protéger ce
qu'il reste des serpents masaga et
augmenter la population
pour elle tout passe par le succès de la
première année d'hibernation
c'est le taux de survie au premier hiver
qu'on veut améliorer
une fois cette première année passée
grâce à un meilleur taux de survie on
espère voir la population augmenter du
fait qu'il y aura plus d'individus qui
atteindront l'âge adulte
pour réussir ce projet elle favorise
donc la naissance des serpents tôt en
laboratoire à l'automne et sont séparés
en deux groupes le premier groupe
passera son hibernation en laboratoire
alors que l'autre passera l'hiver à
l'extérieur cette technique baptisée
hibernation forcée ou hibernation
assisté consiste à prendre à l'automne
des serpents et s'en est allé placer
dans ces tubes enfouis dans le sol dans
des zones où ils pourront survivre au
froid et y resteront tout l'hiver c'est
un tout jeune massa ce gars est là
survécu à son premier hiver grâce à
notre système d'hibernation assister il
repose sur les ponts jumeaux dans ce
petit terrier artificielle que je lui ai
fait et voilà il se réveille déjà prêts
à remuer à miyagi fait ce travail depuis
maintenant quelques années et les
résultats semblent probants
[Musique]
nous avons de la chance d'avoir pu
développer ce programme
je crois que la population is here
prendra du mieux à windsor jonathan
choquette veut tenter la même expérience
pour rebâtir une population
il procède lui aussi par hibernation
forcée
mais avant d'y introduire des serpents
qui proviendraient des laboratoires dany
haguy ils tentent l'expérience avec des
couleuvres et des scientifiques
auparavant qui ont trouvé que les mines
site les mêmes trous ce sont en fait
utilisés par les massages yoga et les
couleuvres et fait que on pense que si
ça fonctionne pour les couleuvres et ça
va fonctionner pour les manceaux grave
depuis fin novembre on est donné les
clubs ici puis on les a inspecté chaque
deux semaines avec un caméra boroscope
fait que là c'est la dernière fois on va
vraiment voir qu'est ce que ça donne ci
est encore en bonne santé
si on peut la libérer
les résultats sont positifs les
couleuvres qu'on a vu déjà sont en bonne
santé sont en vie c'est sec c'est
jonathan choquette pense qu'il sera
bientôt possible de réintroduire le
serpent masaga la prairie ojibway mais
les défis de survie de l'espèce reste
entier c'est bien sûr que la perte
d'habitat 7,1 menace très très sévère
pour les reptiles au canada pour les
serpents ici on a perdu décidément
nation de masse aux gars dans le passé à
cause que le développement urbain à ça
continue la circulation est responsable
d'une bonne part de la mortalité
particulièrement des mâles qui se
déplace beaucoup quand ils traversent
une route leurs chances de survie est
assez mince
et lorsqu'ils sont près des chalets des
gens peuvent accidentellement les
écraser et l'étude
[Musique]
même si le serpent massa soja est un mal
aimé qui peut faire peur pour rallier à
guy il témoigne de l'importance d'une
riche biodiversité
[Musique]
marcher dans un sentier apercevoir un
grand mas à soda lové dans un buisson
c'est un beau spectacle à force de les
étudier on se rend compte à quel point
ils sont intéressants moi ça m'a pris 35
ans pour me glisser dans leur peau à
penser comme ça prend du temps
[Musique]
oh